[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum sport rapport
dem sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers mein name ist andreas sohn
er ich bin selbst herthas sportler und
wir wollen euch hier beim sport die
tollen menschen hinter den sportlichen
erfolgen unserer herres sportlerinnen
und herres sportler präsentieren
näherbringen und heute zu gast
chiara hölzl skispringerin aus salzburg
sehr erfolgreich vor allem der letzte
winter war für sie persönlich ein
highlight winter und das hat auch dazu
geführt dass sie nominiert wurde zur
sportlerin des jahres herzlich
willkommen liebe keller
fangen wir gleich beim letzten winter an
noch befördert ganze wahnsinn
losgegangen ist mit der pandemie hattest
du einen lauf die inklusion in deiner
karriere noch nicht hat es dass gleich
sechs mal platz eins bei weltcupspringen
gewonnen hast du zwischenzeitlich den
gesamtweltcup geführt und im endeffekt
an den seiten platz gemacht wie schaust
du zurück auf diese wahnsinns saison
auch wenn sie jetzt schon ein paar
monate zurück liegt ja ich war echt mega
coole und vorher emotionale saison ja
ich denke aber auch immer wieder gern
zurück weil es waren so für uns in dem
moment wo man einfach wieder schmunzler
ausgeben und es war einfach die beste
saison ist dieser schon gesprochen die
was überhaupt kopp und jedes gen ist das
kannst du dir erklären wie das alles
passiert ist das halt plötzlich ein
weltcup sieg nach dem anderen gefolgt
ist du dich ja da spielen natürlich für
faktoren eine rolle sagte joop ja
einfach geschaut dass er meine schwächen
die was sie kopfarbeit ich habe immer
einen guten sprung zum brachte jahre
davor und hätten beide relativ gut
aufgebraucht und das quasi immer nur
bislang konstant und junge umstellung
steht und material technisch noch ein
bisschen was geändert und japan ist man
dann vielleicht der vorhang gefallen und
somit bin ich dann doch irgendwie
beschläge in floriana kämen habe es
einfach ja die ganze saison genießen
kinder
das ist ein floh angesprochen beim sport
weiß man ja dass das so ein
ausschlaggebender faktor ist
beim springen dann auch so gewesen also
wenn man mal ein zwei super sprünge hat
dass das dann irgendwie wochenende nach
wochenende genau so gut weiterläuft weil
es eben gerade läuft also wo eigentlich
in den zustand an ihr ist wirklich als
ob es nie so wirklich werk nummer wunsch
gewesen ist war ja eben ist erster weg
am wochenende ist sehr sehr gut mit
platz zwei und drei und irgendwie bin
ich dann doch so eine käme und das hat
mir so motiviert weil ich sehen ob wir
sehr sehr viel richtig macht im sommer
und habe es jetzt gut umgebracht und bin
so kulant ist an die server junge war
eigentlich kein nervöses die jahre der
forschung vom winter dover da bin ich
dann irgendwie so eine gute stunde
ich hab das einfach genießen können hat
man keine gedanken gemacht was ist wenn
sondern frei 94
den sprung- und support ist sonder und
ja ich glaube die single du bist jetzt
schon einige jahre dabei auch wenn du
noch sehr jung bis glaubst du dass da
auch ein bisschen schon routine
auch eine rolle mitspielt wenn man schon
einige weltcup winter absolviert hat und
einfach weiß wie die abläufe so
passieren dass man dann einfach die
sicherheit auch bekommt ja ich denke war
durch labor saisonen im weltcup mit der
bayern-bosse frühjahr vorigen sommer
waren für ups und downs dabei und das
macht man einfach stärker und die glaubt
vielleicht war es genau diesen brauch
dass sie dies noch mehr genießen ob
kinder und ein gewisser wenig gewisse
situationen umgeht und ihr habt ihr es
danach ökonomen kinder und das auch noch
aufgefallen ist letzter sein wenn nicht
nur bei dir ist es super gelaufen
sondern auch bei seinen kolleginnen im
team also reihenweise spitzen erfolge
von von allen damen ist das auch etwas
was dann einfach die grundstimmung
antreibt und man einfach davon ausgeht
dass beim nächsten wochenende sowieso
wieder jemand entweder ganz oben steht
oder podium ist bringt das auch was ja
definitiv was wir haben uns gegenseitig
immer weiter post und das trottoir für
ausgemacht weil alle der saisonauftakt
war von jedem wirklich sehr gut
die jungen waren alle mit dabei und das
motiviert und gioia und dem training hat
man sie immer wieder server burschen
kinder ein gewisser okay war man mit
restaurant mannschaft mithalten können
uns nicht so schlecht sein
wir haben alle gut abgeschnitten weil
die weltcups und ich glaube dass das
schon mal was gemacht wird war die
stimmung untereinander viel spaß gehabt
mir miteinander lachen kinder und es hat
sich jeder vier jahre mietfreiheit
wollen den abendstunden ist aber muss
doch aber abgewechselt
und diese hat sich ja sehr viel dazu
beitragen kann dass du ein highlight aus
dem tollen winter irgendetwas was
vielleicht trotzdem noch einmal eine
stufe über allem zu setzen ist
heraussuchen gibt es da was für dich was
da eine besondere emotionale bedeutung
hat ja für mich gibt es eigentlich zwei
weltcup stationen wo es ein bisschen
hervorragend zu machen ist dass
oberstdorf weil natürlich doch nix jahr
die wm beziehungsweise in denen winter
die wm ist und ja da waren einfach das
war große chancen es waren schwierige
bedingungen ist windig es halt krank und
die konkurrenz war stark und dass ich
mir dadurch jetzt noch kinder und das ja
auf mich konzentriert meine sachen gut
erledigt habe und zum anderen natürlich
in simbach der heimwerker hab die ganzen
freunde die familie fans die was da
waren die die stimmung war einfach
gigantisch so von mir bei uns in meinem
werk habe nie gehabt und die leitung
dieser irgendwie zu schätzen wissen und
und gemerkt dass mich das super saison
haben und das hat glaube ich so viel
kemmer und das war schon sehr sehr
speziell da sie doch mal die prüfung
bestanden habe und desserts super am
meisten haben und dann ist die pandemie
gekommen und alles war nicht mehr so wie
vorher weltcup da ist ja auch vorzeitig
beendet worden hieß es dir mit all den
news damals gegangen jeweils alle super
in form du warst du beim form und dann
passiert das wie bis damit umgegangen
ja offen haben wir noch nicht recht über
den mittag war mitten in unserem
geschehen worden aber zum schluss vor wo
er in norwegen haben wir dann immer
schon war informationen von office
kriegt dass man nicht weiß wie es
ausschaut mit die nächsten wettkämpfe
und ich schon relativ abrupt wir haben
uns eigentlich vorbereitet am vormittag
und dann ist irgendwie eben dies käme
noch gesagt so und bitte schön zu fahren
zum walken ist geht leider immer weiter
die meisten
zur berechnung ist es für jeden ist
beste und sicherste dass ihr jetzt den
weg gemacht und schaut dass jeder
rechtzeitig kind bevor dann wirklich
überall lockt ein kind und bist du hier
eigentlich sollten wir so warm in
unserer eigenen wird da haben wir
einfach dass dies gar nichts mitkriegt
weil du bist wo in einem tunnel sorge
hier mal und das war dann irgendwie am
anfang so unreal weil man vorher noch
nie kopfform an muss man haben weil man
hat gar nicht woher so richtig mit krieg
aber natürlich ist weil es war so eng
bei uns fuhren und ich war gerne kopf
richtiger freikommt und habe mich
natürlich gefreut wenn es eine weiterung
das ist was ich hier nochmal spannend
waren aber sowas angepasst was ich hier
für jeden ist beste und messer neue logo
traum kinder und glaube das ist es was
zählt
glaubst du dass wenn die saison regulär
weitergegangen wäre dass der gesamt
weltcupsieg für dich machbar gewesen
wäre
kann man das überhaupt so sagen in der
retrospektive oder ist das einfach nur
journalisten spekulation sagte war
motiviert also ist frei aber riesengroß
dominik huber am freitag gehabt weil es
war irgendwie chance spannend und die
marien war eine super drauf ist zum
schluss immer wieder stärker waren ihr
heimatland die chancen können sie
natürlich viel besser aber ja wir waren
dann nur noch ein weiter und die chance
ja also es war natürlich noch alles
offen
aber das ist natürlich und auch viele
jahre vorher wurde die auch diesen traum
erfüllen kannst wie war dann die die
vorbereitung auf diese saison dadurch
dass dann der lok tor gekommen ist und
das training sicher auch angepasst
werden musste das sommertraining in dem
sinne wahrscheinlich länger gegangen ist
als jetzt wie es ist in der vorbereitung
gegangen
offen war natürlich eine komplette
lockdown aber das war bei uns jetzt vom
training her gar nicht so tragisch
dadurch dass die saison beendet war hab
mal eine pause und zeit zum
durchschnaufen
es war ungewohnt ruhig weil meistens ist
dann wenn die saison doch relativ gut
unterwegs gut war dass man dann gewisse
medien termine einfach einen hall und
das war diesmal ganz fein um einfach ein
couchtisch sitzt und die interviews per
skype machen konnte da eigentlich
relativ wenig das ist sehr sehr ruhig
ich habe zeit gehabt dass sie die ganze
saison so ein bisserl revue passieren
also einmal die schönsten momente noch
mehr ausgibt und die guten also gute
seiten kopf so gern mal
und wo ist es dann bei uns immer wieder
mit dem training los gegangen gemeinsam
aber das war natürlich eine umstellung
weil nur im drei athleten plus trina und
sehr separiert in einem gewissen
zeitfenster nur trainieren hat can rief
er war ja es war dies für und supervisor
durch nicht so sicher sein
einzelsportler aber wie finden wir im
training lebten hat schon vor der
mannschaft und für die anderen athleten
man kann sich auch wie oft schauen und
weiter pushen
das war heute einen rief schon sehr sehr
gut gegeben und deswegen was wir uns
eigentlich jetzt garnicht soo lee
gravierenden einschränkungen ja glaube
dass andere schau wesentlich schlimmer
erwischt jetzt geht es wieder los bei
euch mit eurem weltcup-springen mit der
weltcup saison ist das was du letzten
geschafft hast und das jetzt team
geschafft habt repliziert kann man das 1
1 die von der vorbereitung heraus man
sagt man hat genau das gleiche gemacht
das heißt es müssen jetzt auch die
leistungen genauso sein oder ist das im
skispringen einfach von so vielen
faktoren abhängig dass man das gar nicht
so sagen kann ja natürlich wollte jetzt
dass er seine beste für sie überhaupt ob
over skispringer ist einfach so sensible
sport dort und da spielen zu viele
faktoren miete und das material ist
jetzt aber neuerungen geben die hat man
sie aber wiederherstellen müssen und das
ist im skispringer so schwarz muss sagen
natürlich war mal wieder gern vorn dabei
und mit kämpfen um die sieger war ja die
anderen schlafen nicht und das ist beim
skispringer sehr sehr schwierig aber wir
haben uns hoffentlich wieder gut
aufgestellt und werden natürlich schauen
dass man da wieder mitkämpfen kindern in
den letzten jahren hat er nicht nur im
sport eine große entwicklung genommen
sondern auch die mediale aufmerksamkeit
auch natürlich genährt durch eure
erfolge wie brachte sogar die
entwicklung bisher zufrieden damit oder
gibt es aspekte wo du sagst da muss sich
noch was tun oder findest du das sogar
eher kontraproduktiv dass jetzt auch
viele augen auf tiere schauen oder ist
das ein druck da dadurch entsteht wie
gehst du damit um
naja ausdruck sehr gesellig gar nicht
was ihr für mich speziell ist einfach
ein normaler motivationsschub weil man
merkt der delight du wirst gesenkt für
die leute die leistung mit untergrund
und die fieber mit dir mit und ich finde
das macht es wird schon noch mal aus und
das war speziellen den winter für uns
sehr sehr neu dass man mich für
aufmerksamkeit gekommen weil sonst
kannst du keine andere sportarten
beziehungsweise die skisprung herren
daher war mir relativ früh im fokus das
war natürlich auch ungewohnte situation
aber ich denke mal gesehen dass man sehr
genossen
das ist auch etwas wo du das begrüßt
dass diese entwicklung auch so ist gibt
es trotzdem bereiche wurde sagt da muss
der damen skisport doch noch weiter in
den mittelpunkt oder da muss ich noch
was entwickeln dinge wo du sagst das
bräuchten wir noch um den nächsten
sprung zu machen hast du da wünsche ja
natürlich gibt es immer irgendwo was
wenn man sagt das hätten wir gerne
anders oder besser aber ich sage so wie
man jetzt auf die schon beim
damen-weltcup ich echt schon sehr gut
und natürlich war noch irgendwie bohr
wettkämpfe in dem zeitraum wobei die
janina die vierschanzentournee ist gut
weil meine mutter zugesprochen vier
wochen außer ist ein bisschen schwierig
uns dann erst im jänner wieder
weitergeht
also wir haben trotzdem genügend wird
kämpfe und vielleicht bringt es ja
irgendwann sagen dass die damen archiv
lenke dafür dass wir auf jeden fall ein
wunsch wo würdest du sagen wer da die
faszination für dich beim skifliegen
dadurch dass ich selber noch nie erleben
habt ihr bin ich schon gespannt drauf
und die herren 40 schäume und ja so
ähnlich war oliver springer sieht franzi
über schiefling sinnfreien 7 also wenn
es wieder zum skifliegen geht und das
ist für sie weil die man nur so
highlight und ich hoffe dass mir die
dame miterleben dürfen ein paar sekunden
länger in der luft sei sicher darauf
kommen wir dann auch gleich warum du
überhaupt beim skispringen gelandet wie
soll ich habe in meiner recherche immer
wieder gemerkt dass du gefragt ist was
du von stefan kraft lernen kannst und
und von den herren lernen kannst jetzt
frage ich dich einmal was können die
herren von dir lernen wie du springst
dadurch dass man damals auch
dass sie in dem sinne von dir lernen
können ja das ist immer schwierig zum
sonnen glaubt man zb an ihren songs
dieses ob geschaut wo es dass stefan
jetzt auf der chancen macht weil jeder
ist anders der hauseigene technik und es
wirkt vielleicht nach außen hin ähnlich
aber ich sage man sich mit den bisschen
mehr bewusst siegmar an show details was
anders sein
und ja da hat jeder seine stärken und
schwächen so gemein und denker stärke
von mir ist einfach dass sie knapp
energie am tv bringen also jetzt schon
bissl was in die haxen und das kann ich
mit erkältung sitzen und da ist
vielleicht dauern oder andere bursche
schon als ob die selber gerne so soll
sicher wie eine scheibe abschneiden
jetzt bin ich sehr fasziniert und auch
sehr verängstigt werde ich euch ja
dauernd zu springen
ich kann mir das selber nie vorstellen
aber glaubt dass prinzipiell möglich ein
habe ich sie zu springen geht das
überhaupt oder ist das dann jedoch in
der kategorie lebensgefährlich sollte
man eher sein lassen
ich glaube das schon möglich ist also
früher sind ja eigentlich um stil her um
das kopf da der schwerpunkt für mich ist
einiges bringen und vielleicht ist das
ja auch mal paralympics aber wie bist du
zum skispringen kommen ist nicht die
erste sportart die einem sozusagen
präsentiert wird im laufe einer eine
kinder oder schüler karriere
wie bist du genau zum skispringen
gekommen im verein wird den kurven
dadurch dass mein bruder mit drei opfern
kurzem springer und mir das eigentlich
nie gereizt dass sie war zwar immer gern
zur schau ich bin ich selber nie auf die
idee käme dass sie das machen
dadurch dass mein bruder hat mir ja
nicht immer vor geschickt hat obwohl ja
der ist so quasi aber niemand werde dann
probier das arme und das war eigentlich
das einzige was er gemacht hat und die
neat und ja eigentlich noch am leben
schmälern dass er gesagt hat es eine
hierarchie springt raus die miet- und
das soll man nicht nehmen lassen und
haben wir für die alpine ski zum
borgmann ab und dann auf die chancen
und das gleich zu beweisen dass er die
sehr wohl traum und das war dann ja
eigentlich prüfung und da gibt dann
gleich an diesem tag 15 sprünge gemacht
wenn immer wieder auf wie klaut man
wollte immer wieder gruppen ein bisschen
bett und mit meinem bruder wäre weiter
springt und so ist die motivation und
die freiheit werde ich sagen ich kenne
habt ist sofort geliebt und ich hab dann
relativ schnell ist dass ihr die sache
weiter verfolgen nicht aber was hatte
ich genau daran fasziniert was war das
wo du sagst das war das entscheidende
dass ich die ersten jahre eben dauernd
springen gegangen bin und immer wieder
mehr sprünge gemacht habe was was war da
das entscheidende element hier irgendwie
der anreiz dass man dass man nur weiter
hoch dass man irgendwie domatter
außerdem dass man nur besser auch schon
in der luft und ja dann sehr sehr froh
gestimmt und dadurch dass ein bruder und
ein paar freunde von mir dann mal gucken
ob man diese agieren da waren wir damit
die freunde gemeinsam was kommt und sich
gegenseitig immer bis matchen jörg ehmer
werden entstehen an telemark macht oder
um einen halben meter die nase vorn hat
und so das hat irgendwie als kinder auf
hausgemachte hat noch als kind da
vielleicht weniger respekt vor dem sport
selbst ist ja kein ungefährlicher sport
ich weiß das ist eine heikle thematik
ist im skispringen aber denkt man da
auch an potenzielle stürze oder
potenziell verletzungen die man sich zu
ziehen kann oder ist es einem egal da
also ich habe mir eigentlich gar nicht
im kopf sowie war dort ist dass er immer
wieder hin freier software dabei online
und beim skispringer kurzzeit und ja
dieses an sich denkt man immer macht ist
gern und ohne rücksicht auf verluste
sorge haben wir als kind weil die
oktober aufgeschlagene knie oder so
wegen nichtigkeiten und deswegen war das
ist eigentlich nicht so im kopf denkt
das ist uns gut weil sobald jungs mädels
kommen einfach nimmer befreit von und
diese seien jetzt noch sowas wird nie
irgendwie dabei sein
du sprichst jetzt auch ein aspekt an der
nicht nur sport enorm wichtig ist
sondern gerade im skispringen die
mentale stärke diese mentale sicherheit
tust du da in dem bereich speziell etwas
das du da gut aufgestellt ist oder hast
du das von natur aus und kannst das
einfach ja ich habe als kind war schon
irgendwie so die coole socke und dann
von meiner pubertät beziehungsweise wo
man heute schon märkte kämen ist ein
bisschen die öffentlichkeit zum
nachdenken und werde ein bisschen
unsicher und die soll wieder ein
bisschen verloren meine mentalität sorge
also dass sie das alles ausblenden kann
und du musst echt sagen da bin ich froh
dass sie dann liest ja immer gemeinsam
mit patrick monika und so bausteine die
wahl auch ein abgang sein oder die
weißen verloren habe wieder arbeiten und
kinder
und ja bin ein bisschen selbstsicherer
wandern durch dies dass die ersten
erfolge wieder da waren im sommer show
und ja wohl auch genau gewusst was aus
mir außer kitzelt dass das einzel wieder
chiem was man braucht und ja dafür bin
ich sehr dankbar weil jetzt ihr hobby
war gewisses selbstvertrauen und musik
und natürlich ist da schon wieder durch
gewisse situationen dass man verliert
aber wir finden dann immer wieder guten
weg dass das relativ bald wieder da ist
und man dann denke ich dass er sehr gut
aufgestellt offensichtlich funktioniert
das wenn jetzt ein paar jahre in die
zukunft blickt und wenn die
entwicklungen hoffentlich alle super
weiterlaufen auch was im weltgeschehen
derzeit so passiert und alles wieder
normal wird wohin zieht es dich was ist
ein großes ziel also dass du beim
skifliegen natürlich auch irgendwann
erfolgreich sein wird weil es auch dann
bewerbe für euch geben wird was ist das
große ziel heißt große ziel ist ja für
uns denke meine mädels in der mannschaft
dass man einfach unseren sport noch
weiter pushen dass man nur mehr gesehen
werden dass man dies aber dafür für die
kinder beziehungsweise für die
springerinnen die was ich jetzt aber
auch einen kinder und schülerbereich
sein dass man doch einfach einen schritt
nach vorne machen eben dass man danach
die lücke dort um weihnachten schließt
und msi fliehen
ich denke wenn man da einfach jetzt so
konsequent weiterarbeiten und
ordinationen damit sehen dass man doch
einfach
dafür reichen kindern und das war glaube
ich für uns alle schon ein großes ziel
dass wir das gemeinsam schaffen
es ist spricht jetzt auch sehr viel über
dich dass du an die gesamtentwicklung
des sportes denkst wenn wir nicht nicht
über die zukunftsfrage also das zeigt
dass die radsport auch wirklich am
herzen liegt dass auch die sichtbarkeit
angesprochen
hättest du dir als junge oder noch
jüngere springerin gewissen wir noch
sehr jung gewünscht dass seine sportart
da vielleicht noch mehr sichtbarkeit
hatte dass seine idole vielleicht noch
präsenter gewesen wären möchtest du das
jetzt für junge springerin und
vielleicht auch sein
ja definitiv also die jungs waren
eigentlich meine idole männer also da
waren jetzt die frauen und nicht
wirklich sichtbar sein mag mancher dies
genau verfolgen müssen dass man jetzt
was wer wo genau und wo was für ihre
wettkämpfe stattfinden das war doch sehr
sehr wenig vorhanden und erst wieder
unter richtiger dazu gestoßen bin zum
weltcup sammer bisserl sichtbare waren
sogar neue und präsenter in den medien
und dieses mal ist er hat echt fühler
zur erweiterung dass man da noch einmal
hervor gestrahlt haben und dass unsere
leistungen sogar bastian hat wenig
gespürt aber wahr oder nicht nur einfach
gemeinsam schauen dass man die stoffe
weil ich denke maroni zurück denkt hätte
schon gern ein mädel oder dame aus
vorbild kopf weil es doch hier mal
wieder unsere bezug ist uns uns also
spricht jetzt von mir warum unser dame
ist und ich habe so eine relativ bei dem
wieder im weltcup dabei war da nie als
vorbild sehen will wie sie an die sache
geht unter die serie henriksen oder die
takanashi das waren einfach für mich
schon mal so eine die an ihm ist immer
so weil ich stehe da gott und die
springen zu gut und ich mich da mit ihm
ich die same erreichen und ich glaube
das ist ja so wichtig dass man jetzt für
die kinder und die jugendlichen einfach
ja kurz vorbild ist meistens ist es so
dass wenn in einer sportart das klappt
gut läuft also ich beobachte das jetzt
mal ohne dass es wissenschaftlich
vorstellen dass dann in den jahren
darauf gegen die iren ein boom
passiert ob das jetzt tennis oder auch
im skispringen im herrenbereich jetzt
läuft das glaube ich so gut
glaubst du dass das auch für einen boom
im damen skisprung sport dass wir
nachwuchs jetzt nachkommen kann das
junge mädchen sich dafür entscheiden
skispringen zu gehen
denkst du dass das möglich ist mit glück
bei meinem verein sv schwarzach darum im
winter und drei mädels umfang und ich
sind vorgewarnt wieso sie dort ist
eigentlich dann josia ng carrolls im
fernsehen und die kinder foto diesem
gleichen verein die tat ist gern mal
probieren und die sache mit seiner frau
dabei und das macht mich stolz
und die mädels da eigentlich dass sie da
was auch immer die grundmotivation war
dass sie das überhaupt mal probieren
möchten und ihr team jetzt schon so
einen großen schritt gemacht im sommer
aber uns nicht ganz einfach war zum
trainieren und teilweise dann wieder
passieren haben messen
ich finde dass das macht saß was würdest
du diesen jungen damen mit geben auf
ihrem weg zurück denkt dann mahlzeit die
wahrheit das einzige mädel also dass der
stark bleiben dass sie durch kämpfen
weil die burschen und das doch nicht
aufgeben das ist nicht immer einfach
aber ich sage mal die sonne auch wieder
vor
an dieses denken warum qualitätsagentur
weil das lieb und nicht weil ich sehe
und beweisen möchte und das glaube ich
ist sehr sehr wichtig ich glaube da kann
man sich auf jeden fall
jeder junge springerin etwas mitnehmen
und auch jeder junger springer
das haben wir schon gelernt heute wenn
jetzt gerade nicht dich mit dem
skispringen auseinandersetzen und damit
beschäftigt und er nimmt er als als
profi auch als sportlerin natürlich den
gesamten tagesablauf einer deine
karriere
was sind die dinge die dich noch
faszinieren die dich noch begeistern
aber immerhin in die color die
begeisterte eigentlich jeden tag wieder
als team und ist quasi einfach wer jedes
mal wieder aufs neue hier so und ja ich
sage einfach ich bin generell also sport
mensch sorgen sollten irgendwo auf der
couch zu finden
ich bin immer gerne in der natur liebs
auf die berge und ihm sei egal ob sommer
winter es natürlich
im sommer weil im internet nicht
wirklich die zeit dafür war
oder meinem dennis blos also da glaube
ich finde man mir dann erde haben die
ganze sportstätten wieder
und weil das auch etwas wo du wenn du
nicht nimmt der sportlerin geworden
wärst auch im sommersport irgendwo deine
heimat gefunden hat ist als sportlerin
könntest du dich in einer anderen
sportart vorstellen ja also irgendwas ja
die sicher gefunden weil eben der sport
schon damals sowie sachen ausprobiert
und zum schluss bevor er da wirklich
mich dann entschieden ob die skispringer
professionell machen möchte und als
andere dafür aufgeben wir sieben
verschiedene sportarten gemacht also da
wo es bis jetzt aber so viel dabei und
ebenso viel wintersport dortmund ii oder
winter ist mir dann doch irgendwie ein
bisschen leer weg gehen und so
einzigartig was wir damals schon oder
sie springen weil die damen und ihr
vielleicht ist dann genau das gehen dass
sie welche dies entschieden
auf jeden fall die richtige entscheidung
lässt du keine zweifel auf auch wenn ich
davon überzeugt bin dass andere
sportarten die ich auch sehr gerne in
ihren reihen gehabt haben auf jeden fall
alles gute für den kommenden weltcup
winter bleibt gesund unverletzt und wir
freuen uns auch viel erfolg danke dass
du hier zum sport gekommen
danke clara und danke euch das wars vom
sport rapport bis bald und wir freuen
uns wenn ihr auch beim nächsten mal
wieder mit dabei sagt servus
[Musik]
[Applaus]